well back here at home is coveted
numbers increase across the valley clark
county and other organizations are
providing free
drive through covet 19 testing and
vaccinations
it's a five-day week schedule from
sunday through thursday evenings and
starting today no appointments are
necessary madison kimbrough joins us
live from the unlv stan fulton building
near east flamingo where they're just
getting set up there madison
yeah people started arriving here around
4pm take a look as the turnout is pretty
busy here it's first come
first serve first serve basis while
supplies
last now the site will have about 300
doses of vaccine
and 500 tests each night of operation
now what's interesting about this site
is it's all done through the
drive-through method both coveted 19
test
vaccines will be administered while
sitting in your car
making it extremely convenient they do
ask that you wait 15 minutes in your car
after you get your shot just like you
would do when going in to get it
at the three coped vaccine available at
this site we've got pfizer moderna
which requires two doses and johnson and
johnson's jansen which is just one shot
here's what one local who is getting
tested after just getting back from
vacation
had to say about this method i think
it's
a good idea i mean the numbers are going
up and it's
good to be cautious you know it's good
it's available
again this testing site is located at
the unlv's stan fulton building
parking lot on east flamingo and it
starts at 5
30 and ends tonight at 10 30. so you
have plenty of time
to come on down and wait in line we of
course will be live giving you an
overview
of today's events coming up at 6 pm
madison kimbrough 8 news now